tonight for senator tim scott who
delivered the official republican
rebuttal to president biden's speech to
congress watch
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country
we also heard about a so-called family
plan
even more taxing even more spending
to put washington even more in the
middle of your life
from the cradle to college
we get to live in the greatest country
on earth
the country where my grandfather in his
94 years
saw his family go from cotton
to congress in one lifetime
after that response the senator facing
an onslaught of racist attacks including
on twitter where the hashtag uncle tim
was up trending for 11 hours until the
social media giant finally took it down
senator scott responding to that earlier
today last night what was trending
in social media was uncle tim and they
doubled down
on this concept of liberal oppression
it is stunning in 2021 that those who
speak about ending discrimination
want to end it by more discrimination
the left is
they have doubled down that they are
going to not attack my policies but they
are literally attacking
the color of my skin jesse for a long
time here on the five i've
you know i talk about my communication
rules one of them is never say yes to
doing the rebuttal
to a presidential speech uh he proved me
wrong um
he really nailed it i thought um
so let's get your reactions to his
speech overall and if you want of course
the attacks that came after
well a black republican senator says
america is not racist and white liberals
say no
no it is it is racist they want you to
think this country is racist so blacks
and whites
are against each other and democrats can
then exploit that
divide for power white liberals they
have a savior complex
they want to swoop in and have black
america
be the victim and then save them it
helps them assuage their white guilt
and associate their thirst
for power and control that's what this
is about
they ridicule black republicans because
they're panicked they're going to lose
their base the minute
a black republican emerges onto the
scene they're viciously
smeared that sends a signal to other
black americans don't you dare switch
parties
they're very concerned that they're
losing the grip on black
voters in america and the cries of
racism are going to get louder
and louder as that grip loosens right
now
if you go back in history the democratic
party actually fought to the death
to keep their slaves and the republican
party
is now accused of wanting to put black
americans back in chains
nothing could be further from the truth
the republican party wants black
americans white americans
all americans to be free free from
government oppression
free speech free religion free to keep
and bear arms and free to keep more of
the money
that we earned because the republican
party
trusts the people to control their own
destiny
and the democratic party does not
greg he is a talented uh
speaker and i think that also is another
thing which is
he's i got a temperament and a tone and
an approach
that i think a lot of people like oh
okay he's always easy on the ears and
then but the message is totally
different from what you're hearing from
biden
yeah and also the the hatred the
reaction gave it new life
i think if people hadn't reacted the way
they did on twitter
i mean twitter could have acted faster
than 11 hours i mean
remember how quick they acted to protect
hunter i mean
uh that was that they blocked that
article before it came out um
but to to uh jesse's point there's
nothing scarier
to a white liberal than a black
republican because you can't be a victim
and a republican it's not allowed all
hurdles and obstacles in your life are
seen as fuel for achievement
so rejecting the victim's status makes
tim scott utterly useless
especially to the media and the
democrats that's why they despise him i
give
credit to kamala harris for um agreeing
with tim scott about their that you
america is not a racist country
and you notice that nobody called her
anti-auntie cam
or uncle cam but remember this is all
part of what joe biden said to i guess
it was charlemagne the god
you know if you don't vote for joe you
ain't black it's the plantation of the
mind
um the the democrats need blacks to
believe
that it's only you only have one choice
right there's only one choice liberalism
meaning that you actually really don't
have a choice and if you do choose
something
other than being a liberal then you're
undermining your own blackness
of course they would never say that to a
black man's face they do it on twitter
and juan you've written about this
before and talked about it i mean it's a
little bit of a not a new phenomenon for
black republicans to to kind of get this
these labels
hurled at them
right but i mean so i think twitter was
absolutely right
to take that down i mean i i think it
was offensive
i will say that you know you got to
understand that if twitter acts to
remove
abusive language targeting tim scott you
can we all have to get comfortable with
the idea that they would act to remove
abusive language in
language that targets people on the left
as well
but anyway getting back to the speech i
thought senator scott did a fine job
dana
it's a difficult spot as you said to
speak
in the rebuttal you're speaking after
the president of the united states in
the grand
setting uh basically you're speaking in
a room to a camera
uh his argument though to me was not
that strong
uh in that he was saying well you know
republicans do want
to do something for people who are
hurting and help with the job situation
biden had spoken about you know creating
jobs for the forgotten man
so scott says well no this is all big
socialism big spending and the like
and i just don't think it rang true
given you know that
there was no explicit plan for how
you're going to help people much less
how are you going to explain the fact
that you know republicans didn't care so
much about deficit spending under
president trump
but one the one last thing i'd mentioned
to you is this thing that was raised
earlier about him saying this is
not a racist country i i i didn't have
that thought but
true i don't think it's a racist country
but i do think and this is what people
were
have been saying to me today is yeah but
we have ongoing
racial problems this is a country that
was founded with legalized slavery
and we have ongoing consequences to that
to this day
and so we have to work on it now today
senator scott met with
senator booker senator durbin
representative karen bass and others
on police reform that's part of that
effort
which shows katie that he recognizes the
same thing which
is that we definitely have a pass that
we have to
contend with but we can actually move on
and try to solve some things too
does he have a bright future in your
opinion
he certainly has a bright future and
dana i was also worried when he was
picked to do this because i i like him a
lot and i hope that he has a future and
i think after doing a good job last
night he does
but generally speaking you know he went
after a number of different issues that
democrats have
uh been talking about over the last
couple of months whether it's the
georgia law
or a school choice but what i think is
the most important thing is his
overarching
theme of his speech which was the
american dream and the promise
of america he said original sin is never
the end of the story it's only the
beginning and redemption
is the story of america and he talked
about his own family and how he went
from cotton to congress right
and and how his gr his grandfather used
to read the newspaper
even though he couldn't really read just
to show his grandson an example and to
set an example for him
and so it goes against this entire
argument that we've seen from the left
this happened to be the 1619
project this critical race theory in
schools but america is a good place
although not perfect and it's a place
where people can redeem themselves
and move forward with their lives
whether it's in congress in business
wherever you want to make it in life
america is the place to do it and he is
reluctant to talk about himself but
he did a good job this morning of course
also responding to questions about
the attacks